today's the day of action everybody been
asking why we were just in this park
well now you guys gonna find out while
we're in this park
and everybody should be in the streets
doing something against the wall street
people they are just taking over our
life and now it's take this whole March
was planned before the eviction the
other night and that kind of sealed the
deal on why I wanted to come out from
Boston I've been coming every weekend
nobody really wants to speak for the
whole group everybody has their own
reasons why they're here you know part
of what this movement about is about at
least it's an initial phase is
pinpointing this true centers of power
in this country and we know that
corporations interact to be writing the
legislation that is passed by the people
they pay the politicians are for
these corporations and all these
corporations work for Wall Street and
that's what we need to do this
Wall Street made the Federal Reserve so
they could steal our money skim off our
attacks money they are taking our tax
money at this minute and taking pain or
loan interest rolls to Goldman Sachs
this is why we ought to stop this what
happens in a game of Monopoly when
somebody gets on the property
the game's over and you start another
game the game is over when the
competition stops and that's kind of
where we are in our economic system
oh my Wall Street
and you clever that George take our land